The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Today, we're going to look at
some kind of different data
structures for static trees.
So we have-- at least in
the second two problems--
we have a static tree.
We want to preprocess it
to answer lots of queries.
And all the queries we're
going to support today
we'll do in constant time per
operation, which is pretty
awesome, and linear space.
That's our goal.
It's going to be hard
to achieve these goals.
But in the end, we will
do it for all three
of these problems.
So let me tell you
about these problems.
Range minimum queries, you're
given an array of numbers.
And the kind of query
you want to support--
we'll call RMQ of ij--
is to find the
minimum in a range.
So we have Ai up to Aj and we
want to compute the minimum
in that range.
So i and j form the query.
I think it's pretty
clear what this means.
I give you an interval
that I care about, ij,
and I want to know,
in this range,
what's the smallest value.
And a little more subtle--
this will come up later.
I don't just want to
know the value that's
there-- like say
this is the minimum
among that shaded region.
But I also want to know
the index K between i
and j of that element.
Of course, if I know the index,
I can also look up the value.
So it's more interesting
to know that index.
OK.
This is a non-tree problem,
but it will be closely related
to tree problem, namely LCA.
So LCA problem is you
want to preprocess a tree.
It's a rooted tree, and the
query is LCA of two nodes.
Which I think you know, or
I guess I call them x and y.
So it has two nodes
x and y in the tree.
I want to find their lowest
common ancestor, which
looks something like that.
At some point they
have shared ancestors,
and we want to find
that lowest one.
And then another problem
we're going to solve
is level ancestor,
which again, preprocess
a rooted tree and the query
is a little different.
Given a node and an integer k--
positive integer--
I want to find
the kth ancestor of that node.
Which you might write parent to
the k, meaning I have a node x,
the first ancestor
is its parent.
Eventually want to get
to the kth ancestor.
So I want to jump
from x to there.
So it's like teleporting to
a target height above me.
Obviously, k cannot be larger
than the depth of the node.
So these are the three problems
we're going to solve today,
RMQ, LCA, and LA.
Using somewhat
similar techniques,
we're going to use a
nice technique called
table look-up,
which is generally
useful for a lot
of data structures.
We are working in the
Word RAM throughout.
But that's not as essential as
it has been in our past integer
data structures.
Now the fun thing
about these problems
is while LCA and LA
look quite similar--
I mean, they even share
two letters out of three--
they're quite different.
As far as I know, you need
fairly different techniques
to deal with-- or as
far as anyone knows--
you need pretty
different techniques
to deal with both of them.
The original paper that
solved level ancestors kind of
lamented on this.
RMQ, on the other
hand, turns out
to be basically
identical to LCA.
So that's the more
surprising thing,
and I want to start with that.
Again, our goal is to get
constant time, linear space
for all these problems.
Constant time is easy to
get with polynomial space.
You could just store
all the answers.
There's only n squared different
queries for all these problems,
so quadratic space is easy.
Linear space is the hard part.
So let me tell you
about a nice reduction
from an array to a tree.
Very simple idea.
It's called the Cartesian tree.
It goes back to Gabow
Bentley and Tarjan in 1984.
It's an old idea, but it
comes up now and then,
and in particular,
provides the equivalence
between RMQ and LCA,
or one direction of it.
I just take a minimum element--
let's call it Ai--
of the array.
Let that be the root of my tree.
And then the left
sub-tree of T is just
going to be a
Cartesian tree on all
the elements to the left of i.
So A less than i, and
then the right sub-tree
is going to be A greater than i.
So let's do little example.
Suppose we have 8,
7, 2, 8, 6, 9, 4, 5.
So the minimum in
this rate is 2.
So it gets promoted
to the root, which
decomposes the problem into
two halves, the left half
and the right half.
So drawing the tree, I put 2--
maybe over here is
actually nicer--
2 at the root.
On the left side,
7 is the smallest.
And so it's going to get
promoted to be the root,
and so the left side
will look like this.
On the right side,
the minimum is 4,
so 4 is the right root, which
decomposes into the left half
there, the right half there.
So the right thing is just 5.
Here the minimum is 6, and
so we get a nice binary tree
on the left here.
OK.
This is not a
binary search tree.
It's a min heap.
Cartesian tree is a min heap.
But Cartesian trees have a
more interesting property,
which I've kind of alluded
to a couple of times already,
which is that LCAs in
this tree correspond
to RMQs in this array.
So let's do some examples.
Let's say I do LCA of 7 and 8.
That's 2.
Anything from the left and the
right sub-tree, the LCA is 2.
And indeed, if I take anything,
any interval that spans 2,
then the RMQ is 2.
If I don't span 2, I'm either
in the left or in the right.
Let's say I'm on the right, say
I do an LCA between 9 and 5.
I get 4 because, yeah, the
RMQ between 9 and 5 is 4.
Make sense?
Same problem, really, because
it's all about which mins--
I mean in the sequence of mins--
which mins do you contain?
If you contain
the first min, you
contain the highest
min you contain.
That is the answer and
that's what LCA in this tree
gives you.
So LCA i and j in
this tree T equals
RMQ in the original array of
the corresponding elements.
So there is a bijection
between these items,
and so I and J here
represents nodes,
and here corresponding to
the corresponding items in A.
OK.
So this says if you
wanted to solve RMQ,
you can reduce it
to an LCA problem.
Quick note here, which is--
yeah.
There's a couple of different
versions of Cartesian trees
when you have ties, so
here I only had one 2.
If there was another 2,
then you could either just
break ties arbitrarily
and you get a binary tree,
or you could make them all one
node, which is kind of messier,
and then you get
a non-binary tree.
I think I'll say we
disambiguate arbitrarily.
Just pick any min, and
then you get a binary tree.
It won't affect the answer.
But I think the original paper
might do it a different way.
OK.
Let's see.
So then let me just
mention a fun fact
about this reduction, which
is that you can compute it
in linear time.
This is a fun fact we
basically saw last class,
although in a completely
different setting,
so it's not at all obvious.
But you may recall, we
had a method last time
for building a compressed
trie in linear time.
Basically, same
thing works here,
although it seems
quite different.
The idea is if you
want to build this,
if you build a
Cartesian tree according
to this recursive
algorithm, you will
spend n log n time or actually,
maybe even quadratic time,
if you're computing
min with a linear scan.
So don't use that
recursive algorithm.
Just walk through the array,
left to right, one at a time.
So first you insert 8.
Then you insert
7, and you realize
7 would have would have
won, so you put 7 above 8.
Then you insert 2.
You say that's even higher than
7, so I have to put it up here.
Then you insert 8 so that
you'll just go down from there,
and you put 8 as a
right child of 2.
Then you insert 6.
You say whoops, 6 actually would
have gone in between 2 and 8.
And the way you'd see that is--
I mean, at that moment, your
tree looks something like this.
You've got 2, 8, and there's
other stuff to the left,
but I don't actually care.
I just care about
the right spine.
I say I'm inserting 6.
6 would have been above
8, but not above 2.
Therefore, it fits
along this edge,
and so I convert this
tree into this pattern,
and it will always
look like this.
8 becomes a child of 7--
sorry, 6.
6.
Thanks.
Not 7.
7 was on the left.
This is the guy I'm
inserting next because here.
So I guess it's a left child
because it's the first one.
So we insert 6 like this.
So now the new
right spine is 2, 6,
and from then on,
we will always be
working to the right of that.
We'll never be touching
any of this left stuff.
OK.
So how long did it
take me to do that?
In general, I have a right
spine of the tree, which are all
right edges, and I might
have to walk up several steps
before I discover whoops, this
is where the next item belongs.
And then I convert it
into this new entry,
which has a left child,
which is that stuff.
But this stuff becomes
irrelevant from then
on, because now, this
is the new right spine.
And so if this is a
long walk, I charge that
to the decrease in the
length of the right spine,
just like that
algorithm last time.
Slightly different
notion of right spine.
So same amortization,
you get linear time,
and you can build
the Cartesian tree.
This is actually where
that algorithm comes from.
This one was first, I believe.
Questions?
I'm not worrying too
much about build time,
how long it takes to build
these data structures,
but they can all be
built in linear time.
And this is one of
the cooler algorithms,
and it's a nice tie
into last lecture.
So that's a reduction
from RMQ to LCA,
so now all of our problems are
about trees, in some sense.
I mean, there's a
reason I mentioned RMQ.
Not just that it's a handy
problem to have solved,
but we're actually going
to use RMQ to solve LCA.
So we're going to go back and
forth between the two a lot.
Actually, we'll spend most
of our time in the RMQ land.
So let me tell you about
the reverse direction,
if you want to
reduce LCA to RMQ.
That also works.
And you can kind of
see it in this picture.
If I gave you this
tree, how would you
reconstruct this array?
Pop quiz.
How do I go from here to here?
In-order traversal, yep.
Just doing an in-order
traversal, write those guys--
I mean, yeah.
Pretty easy.
Now, not so easy because
in the LCA problem,
I don't have numbers
in the nodes.
So if I do an in-order
walk and I write stuff,
it's like, what should I
write for each of the nodes.
Any suggestions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The height?
Not quite the height.
The depth.
That will work.
So let's do it,
just so it's clear.
Look at the same tree
Is that the same tree?
Yep.
So I write the depths.
0, 1, 1, 2, 2, 2, 3, 3.
It's either height or depth,
and you try them both.
This is depth.
So I do an in-order
walk I get 2, 1, 0--
can you read my writing--
3, 2, 3, 1, 2.
It's funny doing an in-order
traversal on something that's
not a binary search
tree, but there it is.
That's the order in which
you visit the nodes.
And you stare at it long
enough, this sequence
will behave exactly the
same as this sequence.
Of course, not in terms of
the actual values returned.
But if you do the
argument version of RMQ,
you just ask for what's the
index that gives me the min.
If you can solve RMQ
on this structure,
then that RMQ will give
exactly the same answers
as this structure.
Just kind of nifty.
Because here I had numbers, they
could be all over the place.
Here I have very clean numbers.
They will go between 0 and
the height of the tree.
So in general at
most, 0, 2, n minus 1.
So fun consequence of
this is you get a tool
for universe reduction in RMQ.
The tree problems
don't have this issue,
because they don't
involve numbers.
They involve trees, and that's
why this reduction does this.
But you can start from an
arbitrary ordered universe
and have an RMQ problem on that,
and you can convert it to LCA.
And then you can convert it
to a nice clean universe RMQ,
just by doing the Cartesian
tree and then doing
the in-order traversal
of the depths.
This is kind of nifty because
if you look at these algorithms,
they only assume a
comparison model.
So these don't
have to be numbers.
They just have to be something
from a totally ordered universe
that you can compare
in constant time.
You do this
reduction, and now we
can assume they're integers,
nice small integers, and that
will let us solve things in
constant time using the Word
RAM.
So you don't need to assume
that about the original values.
Cool.
So, time to actually
solve something.
We've done reductions.
We now know RMQ and
LCA are equivalent.
Let's solve them both.
Kind of like the last
of the sorting we saw,
there's going to
be a lot of steps.
They're not sequential steps.
These are like different
versions of a data structure
for solving RMQ,
and they're going
to be getting progressively
better and better.
So LCA which applies RMQ.
This is originally solved
by Harel and Tarjan in 1984,
but is rather complicated.
And then what I'm
going to talk about
is a version from 2000 by
Bender and Farach-Colton,
same authors from the
cache-oblivious B-trees.
That's a much
simpler presentation.
So first step is I want to do
this reduction again from LCA
to RMQ, but slightly
differently.
And we're going to get a more
restricted problem called
plus or minus 1 RMQ.
What is plus or minus 1 RMQ?
Just means that you get an array
where all the adjacent values
differ by plus or minus 1.
And if you look at the
numbers here, a lot of them
differ by plus or minus 1.
These all do.
But then there are
some big gaps--
like this has a gap of
3, this has a gap of 2.
This is plus or minus 1.
That's almost right,
and if you just
stare at this idea
of tree walk enough,
you'll realize a
little trick to make
the array a little bit bigger,
but give you plus or minus
ones.
If you've done a lot
of tree traversal,
this will come quite naturally.
This is a depth first search.
This is how the depth
first search order
of visiting a tree in order.
This is usually called
an Eulerian tour.
The concept we'll come
back to in a few lectures.
But Euler tour just means
you visit every edge twice,
in this case.
If you look at the
node visits, I'm
visiting this node here,
here, and here, three times.
But it's amortized constant,
because every edge is just
visited twice.
What I'd like to do is
follow an Euler tour
and then write down all
the nodes that I visit,
but with repetition.
So in that picture I
will get 0, 1, 2, 1.
I go 0, 1, 2, back to 1,
back to 0, then over to the 1
on the right, then to
the 2, then to the 3,
then back up to the 2,
then down to the other 3,
then back up to the
2, back up to the 1,
back down to the last
node on the right,
and back up and back up.
OK.
This is what we call Euler tour.
So multiple visits--
for example, here's
all the places that
the root is visited.
Here's all the places
that this node is visited,
then this node is
visited 3 times.
It's going to be visited
once per incident edge.
I think you get the pattern.
I'm just going to store this.
And what else am I going to do?
Let's see.
Each node in the tree
stores, let's say,
the first visit in the array.
Pretty sure this is enough.
You could maybe store
the last visit as well.
We can only store a
constant number of things.
And I guess each array
item stores a pointer
to the corresponding
node in the tree.
OK.
So each instance of the 0
stores a pointer to the root,
and so on.
It's kind of what these
horizontal bars are indicating,
but those aren't
actually stored.
OK.
So I claim still RMQ and here
is the same as LCA over there.
It's maybe a little
more subtle, but now
if I want to compute
the LCA of two nodes,
I look at their
first occurrences.
So let's do-- I don't know--
2 and 3.
Here, this 2 and this 3.
I didn't label them, but I
happen to know where they are.
2 is here, and it's the first 3.
Now here, they happen to
only occur once in the tour,
so it's a little clearer.
If I compute the RMQ,
I get this 0, this 0,
as opposed to the other 0s,
but this 0 points to the root,
so I get the LCA.
Let's do ones that do not
have unique occurrences.
So like, this guy and this guy,
the first 1 and the first 2
It'd be this 1 and this 1.
In fact, I think any
of the 2s would work.
Doesn't really matter.
Just have to pick one of them.
So I picked the leftmost
one for consistency.
Then I take the
RMQ, again I get 0.
You can test that
for all of them.
I think the slightly
more subtle case
is when one node is an
ancestor of another.
So let's do that,
1 here and 3 there.
I think here you do need to
be leftmost or rightmost,
consistently.
So I take the 1 and
I take the second 3.
OK.
I take the RMQ of that, I get 1
which is the higher of the two.
OK.
So it seems to work.
Actually, I think it would work
no matter which guy you pick.
I just picked the first one.
OK, no big deal.
You're not going to see why
this is useful for a little bit
until step 4 or something,
but we've slightly
simplified our problem to
this plus or minus 1 RMQ.
Otherwise identical to
this in-order traversal.
So not a big deal, but
we'll need it later.
OK.
That was a reduction.
Next, we're finally going
to actually solve something.
I'm going to do constant
time, n log n space, RMQ.
This data structure will not
require plus or minus 1 RMQ.
It works for any RMQ.
It's actually a
very simple idea,
and it's almost what we need.
But we're going to have to
get rid of this log factor.
That will be step 3.
OK, so here's the idea.
You've got an array.
And now someone gives
you an arbitrary interval
from here to here.
Ideally, I just store the mins
for every possible interval,
but there's n squared intervals.
So instead, what I'm going
to do is store the answer
not for all the intervals, but
for all intervals of length
of power of 2.
It's a trick you've
probably seen before.
This is the easy thing to do.
And then the
interesting thing is
how you make it actually
get down to linear space.
Length, power of 2.
OK.
There are only log n
possible powers of 2.
There's still n different start
points for those intervals,
so total number of
intervals is n log n.
So this is n log n space,
because I'm storing
an index for each of them.
OK.
And then if I have an
arbitrary query, the point is--
let's call it length k--
then I can cover
it by two intervals
of length a power of 2.
They will be the same length.
They will be length
2 to the floor
of log k, the next smaller
power of 2 below k.
Maybe k is a power
of 2, in which case,
it's just one interval
or two equal intervals.
But in general, you just take
the next smaller power of 2.
That will cover more than half
of the thing, of the interval.
And so you have one
that's left aligned,
one that's right aligned.
Together, those will
cover everything.
And because the min operation
has this nifty feature
that you can take the min of
all these, min of all these,
take the min of the 2.
You will get the min overall.
It doesn't hurt to
have duplicate entries.
That's kind of an
important property of min.
It holds for other
properties too,
like max, but not everything.
Then boom, we've solved RMQ.
I think it's clear.
You do two queries, take
the min of the two--
actually, you have to
restore the arg mins.
So it's a little more
work, but constant time.
Cool.
That was easy.
Leave LCA up there.
OK.
So we're almost there, right.
Just a log factor off.
So what technique do we have
for shaving log factors?
Indirection, yeah, our
good friend indirection.
Indirection comes to
our rescue yet again,
but we won't be done.
The idea is, well, want
to remove a log factor.
Before we removed log
factors from time,
but there's no real
time here, right.
Everything's constant time.
But we can use indirection to
shave a log factor in space,
too.
Let's just divide.
So this is again for RMQ.
So I have an array, I'm going
to divide the array into groups
of size, I believe
1/2 log n would
be the right magic number.
It's going to be theta log n,
but I need a specific constant
for step 4.
So what does that mean?
I have the first 1/2 log
n entries in the array.
Then I have the next
1/2 log entries,
and then I have the
last 1/2 log n entries.
OK, that's easy enough.
But now I'd like to tie all
these structures together.
A natural way to do that is with
a big structure on top of size,
n over log n, I guess
with a factor 2 out here.
n over 1/2 log n.
How do I do that?
Well, this is an RMQ problem,
so the natural thing to do
is just take the min
of everything here.
So the red here is going
to denote taking the min,
and take that-- the one
item that results by taking
the min in that group, and
promoting it to the next level.
This is a static thing
we do ahead of time.
Now if I'm given
a query, like say,
this interval, what
I need to do is first
compute the min in this range
within a bottom structure.
Maybe also compute the
min within this range,
the last bottom structure,
and then these guys
are all taken in entirety.
So I can just take the
corresponding interval up here
and that will give me
simultaneously the mins
of everything below.
So now a query is going to be
the min of two bottoms and one
top.
In other words, I do one
top RMQ query for everything
between, strictly
between the two ends.
Then I do a bottom query for
the one end, a bottom query
for the other end.
Take the min of all those
values and really, it's
the arg min, but.
Clear?
So it would be
constant time if I
can do bottom in
constant time, if I
can do top in constant time.
But the big win is that
this top structure only has
to store n over log n items.
So I can afford an n log
n space data structure,
because the logs cancel.
So I'm going to use
structure 2 for the top.
That will give me constant
time up here, linear space.
So all that's left is to solve
the bottoms individually.
Again, similar kind of
structure to [INAUDIBLE]..
We have a summary structure and
we have the details down below.
But the parameters
are way out of whack.
It's no longer root n, root n.
Now these guys are super
tiny because we only
needed this to be a
little bit smaller than n,
and then this would work
out to linear space.
OK.
So step 4 is going to be how do
we solve the bottom structures.
So step 4.
This is where we're going to
use technique of lookup tables
for bottom groups.
This is going to be
slightly weird to phrase,
because on the one hand,
I want to be thinking
about an individual group,
but my solution is actually
going to solve all
groups simultaneously,
and it's kind of important.
But for now, let's just
think of one group.
So it has size n prime
and n prime is 1/2 log n.
I need to remember
how it relates
to the original value of n so
I know how to pay for things.
The idea is there's really
not many different problems
of size 1/2 log n.
And here's where we're going
to use the fact that we're
in plus or minus 1 land.
We have this giant
string of integers.
Well, now we're looking
at log n of them
to say OK, this here, this
is a sequence 0, 1, 2, 3.
Over here a 0, 1, 2, 1.
There's all these
different things.
Then there's other
things like 2, 3, 2, 3.
So there's a couple
annoying things.
One is it matters what
value you start at, a b,
and then it matters what the
sequence of plus and minus 1s
are after that.
OK.
I claim it doesn't really
matter what value you start at,
because RMQ, this query,
is invariant under adding
some value x to all entries,
all values, in the array.
Or if I add 100 to every
value, then the minimums
stay the same in position.
So again, here I'm thinking
of RMQ as an arg min.
So it's giving just the
index of where it lives.
So in particular, I'm going
to add minus the first value
of the array to all values.
I should probably call this--
well, yeah.
Here I'm just thinking about
a single group for now.
So in a single group, saying
well, it starts at some value.
I'm just going to
decrease all these things
by whatever that value is.
Now some of them
might become negative,
but at least now
we start with a 0.
So what we start
with is irrelevant.
What remains, the remaining
numbers here are completely
defined by the gaps
between or the difs
between consecutive
items, and the difs
are all plus or minus 1.
So now the number of possible
arrays in a group, so
in a single group, is
equal to the number
of plus or minus 1 strings
of length n prime, which is
1/2 log n.
And the number of plus or
minus 1 strings of length
n prime is 2 to the n prime.
So we get 2 to the 1/2 log n,
also known as square root of n.
Square root of n is small.
We're aiming for linear space.
This means that for every--
not only for every group,
there is n over log n groups--
but actually many of the
groups have to be the same.
There's n over log n groups,
but there's only root n
different types of groups.
So on average, like root n
over log n occurrences of each.
So we can kind of compress
things down and say hey,
I would like to just
like store a lookup
table for each one of these, but
that would be quadratic space.
But there's really only square
root of n different types.
So if I use a layer of
indirection, I guess--
different sort of
indirection-- if I just
have, for each of
these groups, I just
store a pointer to the
type of group, which
is what the plus or
minus 1 string is,
and then for that type,
I store a lookup table
of all possibilities.
That will be efficient.
Let me show that to you.
This is a very handy idea.
In general, if you have a lot
of things of size roughly log n,
lookup tables are a good idea.
And this naturally arises
when you're using indirection,
because usually you just
need to shave a log or two.
So here we have these
different types.
So what we're going to do
is store a lookup table that
says for each group
type, I'll just
say a lookup table
of all answers,
do that for each group type.
Group type, meaning the
plus or minus 1 string.
It's really what
is in that group
after you do this shifting.
OK.
Now there's square
root of n group types.
What does it take to
store the answers?
Well, there is, I guess, 1/2
log n squared different queries,
because n prime is
1/2 log n, and a query
is defined by the two endpoints.
So there's at most
this many queries.
Each query, to store the answer,
is going to take order log log
n bits-- this is
if you're fancy--
because the answer is an index
into that array of size 1/2 log
n, so you need log log n
bits to write down that.
So the total size
of this lookup table
is the product of these things.
We have to write root
n look up tables.
Each stores log squared
n different values,
and the values require
log log n bits.
So total number of
bits is this thing,
and this thing is little o of n.
So smaller than linear,
so it's irrelevant.
Can store for free.
Now if we have a bottom group,
the one thing we need to do
is store a pointer
from that bottom group
to the corresponding section of
the lookup table for that group
type.
So each group stores a
pointer into lookup table.
I'm of two minds whether I
think of this as a single lookup
table that's parameterized
first by group type,
and then by the query.
So it's like a two-dimensional
table or three-dimensional,
depending how you count.
Or you can think of there being
several lookup tables, one
for each group type,
and then you're
pointing to a
single lookup table.
However, you want to think
about it, same thing.
Same difference, as they say.
This gives us linear space.
These pointers
take linear space.
The top structure takes
linear space linear number
of words, and
constant query time,
because lookup
tables are very fast.
Just look into them.
They give you the answer.
So you can do a lookup table
here, lookup table here.
And then over here,
you do the covering
by 2, powers of 2 intervals.
Again, we have a lookup
table for those intervals,
so it's like we're
looking into four tables,
take the min of them all, done.
That is RMQ, and also LCA.
Actually it was really LCA that
we solved, because we solved
plus or minus 1
RMQ, which solved
LCA, but by the
Cartesian tree reduction,
that also solves RMQ.
Now we solved 2 out
of 3 of our problems.
Any questions?
Level ancestors are going to
be harder, little bit harder.
Similar number of steps.
I'd say they're a
little more clever.
This I feel is pretty easy.
Very simple style of
indirection, very simple style
of enumeration here.
It's going to be a little more
sophisticated and a little bit
more representative of
the general case for level
ancestors.
Definitely fancier.
Level ancestors is a similar
story we solved a while ago,
but it was kind of a
complicated solution.
And then Bender
and Farach-Colton
found it and said hey,
we can simplify this.
And I'm going to give you
the simplified version.
So this is level ancestors.
Says originally solved
by Berkman and Vishkin
in 1994, OK, not so long ago.
And then the new
version is from 2004.
Ready?
Level ancestors.
What was the problem again?
Here it is.
I gave you a rooted
tree, give you a node,
and a level that I want to go
up, and then I level up by k,
so I go to the kth ancestor,
or parent to the k.
This may seem
superficially like LCA,
but it's very different,
because as you can see,
RMQ was very specific to LCA.
It's not going to let you solve
level ancestors in any sense.
I don't think.
Maybe you could try to do
the Cartesian tree reduction,
but solution we'll see
is completely different,
although similar in spirit.
So step 1.
This one's going to
be a little bit less
obvious that we will succeed.
Here we started with
n log n space which
is shaving a log, no big deal.
Here, I'm going to give
you a couple of strategies
that aren't even constant time,
they're log time or worse.
And yet you combine them
and you get constant time.
It's crazy.
Again, each of the
pieces is going
to be pretty intuitive,
not super surprising,
but it's one of
these things where
you take all these ingredients
that are all kind of obvious,
you stare at them for a while
like, oh, I put them together
and it works.
It's like magic.
All right, so first goal is
going to be n log n space,
log n query.
So here's a way to do it with a
technique called jump pointers.
In this case, nodes are going to
have log n different pointers,
and they're going
to point to the 2
to the ith ancestor for all i.
I guess maximum possible
i would be log n.
You can never go up more than n.
So I mean, ideally you'd have
a pointer to all your ancestors
in array, boom.
In the quadratic space,
you solve your problem
in constant time.
But it's a little
more interesting.
Now every node only has pointers
to log n different places
so it's looking like this.
This is the ancestor path.
So n log n space, and
I claim with this,
you can roughly do a binary
search, if you wanted to.
Now we're not actually going
to use this query algorithm
for anything, but I'll
write it down just
so it feels like we've
accomplished something, mainly
log n query time.
So what do I do?
I set x to be the 2 to the
floor log kth ancestor of x.
OK, remember we're given
a node x and a value
k that we want to rise by.
So I take the power
of 2 just below k--
that's 2 the floor log k.
I go up that much,
and that's my new x,
and then I set k to
be k minus that value.
That's how much I
have left to go.
OK.
This thing will be
less than k over 2.
Because the next previous
power of 2 is at least,
is bigger than
half of the thing.
So we got more
than halfway there,
and so after log n iterations,
we'll actually get there.
That's pretty easy.
That's jump pointers to two
logs that we need to get rid of,
and yes, we will use
indirection, but not yet.
First, we need some
more ingredients.
This next ingredient
is kind of funny,
because it will seem useless.
But in fact, it is useful as
a step towards ingredient 3.
So the next trick is called
long path decomposition.
In general, this class covers
a lot of different treaty
compositions.
We did preferred path
decomposition for tango trees.
We're going to do long path now.
We'll do another one
called heavy path later.
There's a lot of them out there.
This one won't seem
very useful at first,
because while it will
achieve linear space,
it will achieve the amazing
square root of n query, which
I guess is new.
I mean, we don't know how to
do that yet with linear space.
Not so obvious
how to get root n.
But anyway, don't worry
about the query time.
It's more the concept of
long path that's interesting.
It's a step in the
right direction.
So here's what here's how we're
going to decompose a tree.
First thing we do is find the
longest route to leaf path
in the tree, because
if you look at a tree,
it has some wavy bottom.
Take the deepest node.
Take the path the unique path
from the root to that node.
OK.
When I do that, I could
imagine deleting those nodes.
I mean, there's
that path, and then
there's everything
else, which means
there's all these triangles
hanging off of that path, some
on the left, some on the right.
Actually, I haven't
talked about this,
but both LCA and level ancestors
work not just for binary trees.
They work for arbitrary trees.
And somewhere along here--
yeah, here.
This reduction of
using the Euler tour
works for non-binary trees, too.
That's actually
another reason why
this reduction is better than
in-order traversal by itself.
In-order traversal works
only for binary trees.
This thing works for any tree.
In that case, in
an arbitrary tree,
you visit the node many,
many times potentially.
OK, but it will
still be linear space
and everything will still work.
Here also, I want to
handle non-binary trees.
So I'm going to draw
things hanging off,
but in fact, there might be
several things hanging off
here, each their
own little tree.
OK, but the point is--
where's my red.
Here.
There was this one path in the
beginning, the longest path,
and then there's stuff
hanging off of it.
So just recurse on all the
things hanging off of it.
Recursively decompose
those sub-trees.
OK.
Not clear what this
is going to give you.
In fact, it's not
going to be so awesome,
but it will be a starting point.
Now you can answer a query
with this, as follows.
Query-- oh, sorry.
I should say how we're
actually storing these paths.
Here's the cool idea
with this path thing.
I have this path.
I'd like to be able to
jump around at least--
suppose your tree was a path.
Suppose your tree were a path.
Then what would you want to do?
Store the nodes in an
array ordered by depth,
because then if
you're a position i
and you need to go to
position i minus k, boom.
That's just a look
up into your array.
So I'm going to store
each path as an array,
as an array of nodes or
node pointers, I guess,
ordered by depth.
So if it happens, so if my query
value x is somewhere on this
path, and if this path
encompasses where I need
to go-- so if I need to go
k up and I end up here--
then that's instantaneous.
The trouble would be
is if I have a query,
let's say, over here.
And so there's going to be
a path that guy lives on,
but maybe the kth ancestor
is not on that path.
It could be on a higher up path.
It could be on the
red path, and I can't
jump there instantaneously.
Nonetheless, there is a
decent query algorithm here.
All right.
So Here's what
we're going to do.
If k is less than or equal
to the index i of node
x on its path.
So every node belongs
to exactly one path.
This is a path decomposition.
It's a partition of
the tree into paths.
Not all the edges
are represented,
but all the nodes are there.
All the nodes
belong to some path,
and we're going to store,
for every node, store
what its index is and where
it lives in its array.
So look at that
index in the array.
If k is less than or
equal to that index,
then we can solve
our problem instantly
by looking at the path
array at position i minus k.
That's what I said before.
If our kth ancestor
is within the path,
then that's where it
will be, and that's
going to work as long
as that is non-negative.
If I get to negative, that
means it's another path.
So that's the good case.
The other case is
we're just going to do
some recursion, essentially.
So we're going to go as high
as we can with this path.
We're going to look at
path array at position 0.
Go to the parent of that.
Let's suppose every node
has a parent pointer.
That's easy, regular tree, and
then decrease k by 1 plus i.
So the array let us
jump up i steps--
that's this part--
and then the parent
stepped us up one more step.
That's just to get to
the next path above us.
OK, so how much did
this decrease k by?
I'd like to say a factor of
2 and get log n, but in fact,
no, it's not very good.
It doesn't decrease
k by very much.
It does decrease k,
guaranteed by at least 1,
so it's definitely linear time.
And there's a bad
tree, which is this.
It's like a grid.
Whoa.
Sorry.
OK, here's a tree.
It's a binary tree.
And if you set it up right,
this is the longest path.
And then when you decompose,
this is the longest path,
and this is the longest path,
this is the longest path.
If you query here,
you'll walk up to here,
and then walk up to here,
and walk up to here,
and walk up to here.
So this is a square root of n
lower bound for this algorithm.
So not a good algorithm
yet, but the makings
of a good algorithm.
Makings of step 3, which is
called ladder decomposition.
Ladder decomposition is
something I haven't really
seen anywhere else.
I think it comes from
the parallel algorithms
world in general.
And now we're going to achieve
linear space log n query.
Now this is an improvement.
So we have, at the
moment, n log n space,
log n query or n
space root n query.
We're basically taking
the min of the two.
And so we're getting
linear space log n query.
Still not perfect.
We want constant query.
That's when we'll use
indirection, I think.
Yeah, basically, a new type
of indirection, but OK.
So linear space log n query.
Well, the idea is just
to fix long paths,
and it's a crazy idea, OK.
Let me tell you the
idea and then it's
like, why would that be useful.
But it's obvious that
it doesn't hurt you, OK.
When we have these paths,
sometimes they're long.
Sometimes they're
not long enough.
Just take each of
these paths and extend
them upwards by a factor of 2.
That's the idea.
So take number 2, extend
each path upward 2 x.
So that gives us call a ladder.
OK, what happens?
Well, paths are
going to overlap.
Fine.
Ladders overlap.
The original paths
don't overlap.
Ladders overlap.
I don't really care
if they overlap.
How much space is there?
It's still linear space, because
I'm just doubling everything.
So I've most doubled space
relative to long path
decomposition.
I didn't mention it explicitly,
but long path decomposition
is linear space.
We're just partitioning up
the tree into little pieces.
Doesn't take much.
We have to store those
arrays, but every node
appears in exactly
one cell here.
Now every node will
appear in, on average,
two cells in some weird way.
Like what happens over here?
I have no idea.
So this guy's length 1.
It's going to grow to length 2.
This one's length 2, so
now it'll grow to length 4.
This one's length 3--
and it depends on how you count.
I'm counting nodes here.
That's going to go here,
all the way the top.
Interesting.
All the others
will go to the top.
So if I'm here, I walk here.
Then I can jump all
the way to the top.
the way to the root.
Not totally obvious, but it
actually will be log n steps.
Let's prove that.
This is again something
we don't really
need to know for
the final solution,
but kind of nice, kind of
comforting to know that we've
gotten down a log n query.
So it's at most
double the space.
This is still linear.
Now-- oh, there's one catch.
Over in this world,
we said each--
I didn't say it.
I mentioned it out loud.
Every node stores what
array it lives in.
Now a node lives in
multiple arrays, OK.
So which one do I
store a pointer to?
Well, there's one obvious
one to store a pointer to.
Whatever node you take
lives in one path.
In that long path decomposition,
it still lives in one path.
Store a pointer
into that ladder.
So node stores a pointer you
could say to the ladder that
contains it in the lower half.
That corresponds to the one
where it was an actual path.
And only one ladder will contain
a node in its lower half.
The upper half
was the extension.
I guess it's like those
folding ladders you extend.
OK.
Cool.
So that's what we're
going to do and also store
its index in the array.
Now we can do exactly this
query algorithm again,
except now instead of
path, it says ladder.
So you look at the index
of the node in its ladder.
If that index is
larger than k, then
boom, that ladder array will
tell you exactly where to go.
Otherwise you go to
the top of the ladder
and then you take
the parent pointer,
and you decrease by this.
But now I claim that
decrease will be substantial.
Why?
If I have a node of height h--
remember, height of a node
is the length of the longest
path from there downward--
it will be on a ladder
of height at least 2h.
Why?
Because if you look at
a node of height h--
like say, I don't
know, this node--
the longest path from
there is substantial.
I mean, if it's height h, then
the longest path from there
is length at least h.
So every node of height h will
be on a path of length at least
h, and from there down.
And so you look at the ladder.
Well, that's going
to be double that.
So the ladder will be
height at least 2h,
which means if your
query starts at height h,
after you do one step
of this ladder search,
you will get to height at least
2h, and then 4h, and then 8h.
You're increasing your height by
a power of 2, by a factor of 2
every time.
So in log n steps, you will
get to wherever you need to go.
OK You don't have to
worry about overshooting,
because that's the case
when the array tells you
exactly where to go.
OK.
Time for the climax.
It won't be the end,
but it's the climax
in the middle of the story.
So we have on the one
hand, jump pointers.
Remember those?
Jump pointers made small
steps initially and got--
actually, no.
This is what it looks like
for the data structure.
But if you look
at the algorithm,
actually it makes a big
step in the beginning.
Right?
It gets more than halfway there.
Then it makes smaller
and smaller steps,
exponentially decreasing steps.
Finally, it arrives
at the intended node.
Ladder decomposition
is doing the reverse.
If you start at
low height, you're
going to make very small
steps in the beginning.
As your height
gets bigger, you're
going to be making
bigger and bigger steps.
And then when you jump over your
node, you found it instantly.
So it's kind of the
opposite of jump pointers.
So what we're going to
do is take jump pointers
and add them to
ladder decomposition.
Huh.
This is, I guess, version 4.
Combine jump pointers from
one and ladders from three.
Forget about two.
Two is just a warm up for three.
Long paths, defined ladders.
So we've got one way
to do log n query.
We've got another way
I combine them, and
I get constant query.
Because log n plus
log n equals 1.
I don't know.
OK, here's the idea.
On the one hand, jump pointers
make a big step and then
smaller steps, right.
Yeah, like that.
And on the other hand,
ladders make small steps.
It's hard to draw.
What I'd like to do is take
this step and this step.
That would be good,
because only two of them.
So query is going to do
one jump, plus 1 ladder,
in that order.
See, the thing about
ladders is it's
really slow in the beginning,
because your height is small.
I really want to
get large height.
Jump pointers give
you large height.
The very first step, you get
half the height you need.
That's it.
So when we do a jump, we do
one step of the jump algorithm.
What do we do?
We reach height at
least k over 2 above x.
All right, we get halfway there.
So our height-- it's a little--
let's say x has height h.
OK, so then we get to
height-- this is saying we
get to height h plus k over 2.
OK, that's good.
This is a big height.
Halfway there, I mean, halfway
of the remainder after h.
Now ladders double your
height in every step.
So ladder step-- so
this is the jump step.
If you do one ladder step, you
will reach height double that.
So it's at least
2 h plus k, which
is bigger than what we need.
We need h plus k.
That's where we're trying to go.
And so we're done.
Isn't that cool?
So the annoying part is
there's this extra part here.
This is the h part and
we start at some level.
We don't know where.
This is x.
The worst case is maybe
when it's very small,
but whatever it is, we do this
step and this is our target up
here.
This is height h plus k.
In one step, we get
more than halfway
there with the jump pointer.
And then the ladder will
carry us the rest of the way.
Because this is the ladder.
We basically go horizontally
to fall on this ladder,
and it will cover
us beyond where
we need to go, beyond
our wildest imaginations.
So this is k over 2.
Because not only
will it double this,
which is what we
need to double, it
will also double whatever
is down here, this h part.
So it gets us way beyond
where we need to go.
I mean, could be h 0.
Then it gets us to exactly
where we need to go.
But then the ladder
tells us where to go.
So two steps constant time.
Now one annoying thing is
we're not done with space.
So this is the anticlimax part.
It's still going to
be pretty interesting.
We've got to shave off
a log factor in space,
but hey, we're experienced.
We already did that once today.
Question?
Yeah.
Why is it OK to go
past your target?
The question was why is it
OK to go past our target?
Jump pointers aren't
allowed, because they only
know how to go up.
They can't overshoot.
That's why they went less than
halfway, or more than halfway,
but less than the full way.
Ladder decomposition can go
beyond, because as soon as--
the point is, as soon as--
here's you, x, and here's
your kth ancestor.
This is the answer.
As soon as you're in
a common ladder, then
the array tells you where to go.
So even though the top
of the ladder overshot,
there will be a
ladder connecting you
to that top of the ladder.
So as long as it's somewhere
in between, it's free.
Yeah, so that's why it's OK
this goes potentially too high.
So it's good for ladders,
not good for jumps,
but that's exactly where
we have it Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
jump pointers,
wouldn't you be high
up enough in the tree
so that just the
long path would work?
PROFESSOR: Oh,
interesting question.
So would it be enough to do
jump pointers plus long path?
My guess is no.
Jump pointers get you up to--
so think of the
case where h is 0.
Initially you're at height 0.
I think that's going
to be a problem.
You jump up to height k
over 2 with a jump pointer.
Now long path
decomposition, you know
that the path will have a
length at least k over 2,
but you need to get up to k.
And so you may get stuck
in this kind of situation
where maybe you're
trying to get to the root
and you jumped to here,
but then you have to walk.
So I think the long
path's not enough.
You need that factor of 2,
which the ladders give you.
You can see where ladders
come from now, right?
I mean we got up
to height k over 2.
Now we just need to double it.
Hey, we can afford
to double every path,
but I think we need to.
Are there questions?
OK.
So last thing to do is to shave
off this log factor of space.
Now, we're going to do that
with indirection, of course,
constant time and log n space.
But it's not our usual
type of indirection.
Use this board.
Indirections.
So last time we did indirection,
it was with an array.
And actually pretty much
every indirection we've done,
it's been with an
array-like thing.
We could decompose into
groups of size log n,
the top thing was n over log n.
So it was kind of clean.
This structure is not so
clean, because it's a tree.
How do you decompose a
tree into little things
at the bottom of size
log n and a top thing
of size n over log n?
Suppose, for example,
your tree is a path.
Bad news.
If my tree were a path,
well, I could trim off
bottom thing of size log n.
But now the rest is of size
n minus log n, not n divided
by log n.
That's bad.
I need to shave a factor of
log n, not an additive log n.
Can you tell me a good
thing about a path?
I mean, obviously, when
we can put in an array.
But can you quantify
the goodness,
or the pathlikedness of a tree?
I erase this board.
Kind of a vague question.
Good thing about
a path is that it
doesn't have very many leaves.
That's one way to
quantify pathedness.
Small number of leaves, I
claim life's not so bad.
I actually need to do that
before we get to indirection.
Step 5 is let's tune
jump pointers a bit.
I want to make them--
so they're the problem, right?
That's where we
get n log n space.
They're the only source
of our n log n space.
So what I'd like to do is
in this situation where
the number of leaves is small--
we'll see what small
is in a moment--
I would like jump pointers
to be linear size.
OK, here's the idea.
First idea is let's just store
jump pointers from leaves.
OK.
So that would imply
l log n space,
I guess, plus linear overall.
Instead of n log n, now we
just pay for the leaves,
except we kind of
messed up our query.
First thing query did was at the
node, follow the jump pointer.
But it's not so bad.
Here we are at x.
There's some leaves
down here, and we want
to jump up from here, from x.
How do I jump from x?
Well, if I could somehow
go from x to really,
any leaf, the ancestors
of x that I care about
are also ancestors of
any leaf descendant of x.
So all I need to do
is store for each node
any leaf descendant,
single pointer--
this'll be linear--
from every node.
OK so I start at x.
I jump down to an arbitrary
leaf, say this one.
And now I have to do a query.
Jump down, and let's
say I jumped down by d.
Then my k becomes
k plus d, right.
If I went down by d,
and I want to go up
by k from my original point,
now I have to go up by k plus d.
But hey, we know how to
go up from any node that
has jump pointers.
So now we have a
new node, a leaf.
So it has a jump pointer,
has jump pointers, upward.
So we follow that one jump
pointer to get us halfway there
from our new starting point.
We follow one
ladder thing, and we
can get to the level ancestor
k plus d from the leaf,
and that's the level
ancestor k from x.
OK, this is like a reduction
to the leaf situation.
We really don't have to support
queries from arbitrary nodes.
Just go down to a leaf
and then solve the problem
from the leaf.
OK.
OK, so now, if the
number leaves is small,
my space will get small.
How small does l have to be?
n divided by log n.
Interesting.
If I could get the top structure
to not have n over log n nodes,
that's not possible.
I can, at best, get to
n minus log n nodes.
But if I could get it down
to n over log n leaves, that
would be enough to
make this linear space,
and indeed, I can.
This is a technique called tree
trimming, or I call it that.
I don't know if
anyone else does.
But I think I've called
it that in enough papers
that we're allowed
to call it that.
Originally invented by
[? Al ?] [? Strip ?] and others
for a particular data structure.
There's many versions of it.
We will see other versions
in future lectures,
but here's the version
you need for this problem.
OK, here's the plan.
I have a tree and
I want to identify
all the maximally deep nodes
that have at least log n
nodes below them.
This will seem weird,
because we really
care about leaves, and so on.
So there's stuff hanging
off here, whatever.
I guess I'm thinking of
that as one big tree.
No, actually I'm not.
I do need to separate these out.
But one of these nodes could
have arbitrarily many children.
We have no idea.
It's a arbitrary tree.
OK, and what I know is that
each of these triangles
has size less than 1/4 log n.
Because otherwise, this
node was not maximally deep.
So if this had size greater
or equal than 1/4 log n,
then that would have been the
node where I cut, not this one.
So I'm circling the
nodes that I cut below,
so meaning I cut these edges.
OK, so these things have
size less than 1/4 log n,
but these nodes have at least
1/4 log n nodes below them.
So how many of these
circle nodes are there?
Well, at most, 4 n over
log n such nodes, right,
because I can charge
this node to at least 1/4
log n nodes that disappear
in the top structure.
But these things become
the leaves, right.
If I cut all the edges
going down from there,
that makes it a leaf.
And they're the only leaves.
Are they the only leaves?
Yeah.
If you look at a leaf, then it
has size less than 1/4 log n.
So you will cut
above it somewhere.
So every old leaf
will be down here,
and the only new leaves
will be the cut nodes.
OK.
So we have order n
over log n leaves.
Yes, good.
So it's funny.
We're cutting according
to counting nodes,
descendants, not leaves.
Won't work if you
cut with leaves--
cut with nodes.
But then the thing that we care
about is the number of leaves
went down.
That will be enough.
Great.
So up here, we can afford to
use 5, the tuned jump pointer,
combined with ladder structure.
Because this only costs l log n.
l is now n over log n,
so the log n's cancel.
So linear space to
store the jump pointers
from these circled nodes.
So if our query is
anywhere up here,
then we go to a descendant
leaf in the top structure.
And we can go wherever
we need to go.
If our query is in one
of the little trees
at the bottom, which are small,
they're only 1/4 quarter log n,
so we're going to
use a lookup table.
Either answer is
inside the triangle,
in which case, we really
need to query that structure.
Or it's up here.
If it's up here, we just
need to know, basically,
if every node down here stores
a pointer to the dot above it.
Then we can first go there
and see, is that too high?
If it's too high, then
our answer is in here.
If it's not too
high, then we just
do the corresponding
query in structure 5.
OK, so the last
remaining thing is
to solve a query that stays
entirely within a triangle, so
a bottom structure, and that's
where we use lookup tables.
Again, things are going
to be similar to last time
except for now, to step 7.
But it's a little bit messier
because instead of arrays,
we have trees.
And here it's like we graduate
from baby [INAUDIBLE] which is
how many plus or minus
1 strings there are--
power of 2-- to how
many trees are there.
Anyone know how many trees
on n nodes there are?
One word answer.
No.
Nice.
That is a correct
one word answer.
Very good.
Not the one I had in
mind, but anyone else?
Nope.
You're thinking end to the end.
That would be bad.
We could not afford that,
because log n to log n
is super polynomial.
Fortunately it's not that big.
Hmm?
AUDIENCE:
PROFESSOR: It's
roughly 4 to the n.
The correct answer-- I
mean the exact answer--
is called the Catalan number,
which didn't tell you much.
I didn't write it
down, but I'm pretty
sure it is 2 n prime choose
n prime 1 over n prime plus 1
ish?
Don't quote me on that.
It's roughly that.
Might be exactly that.
Someone with internet can check.
But it is at most
4 to the n prime.
The computer science
answer is 4 to the n.
Indeed.
It's just some asymptotics here.
Why is it 4 to the n?
4 to the n you could also
write as 2 to the 2 n
prime, which is--
first, let's check this
is good, and then I'll
explain why this is true
in a computer science way.
So we got 1/4 log n up here.
So the one 2 cancels
with one 2 up here.
So we have 2 to the 1/2 log n.
This is our good friend root n.
Root n is just something
that's n to the something,
but is n to the
something less than 1.
So we can afford
some log factors.
Why are there only 2
to the 2 n prime trees?
One way to see that is you can
encode a tree using 2n bits.
If I have an n node tree, I
can encode it with 2n bits.
How?
Do an Euler tour.
And all you really need
to know from an Euler tour
to reconstruct the
tree is at each step,
did I go down or did I go up?
Those are the only
things you can do.
If you went down,
it's to a new child.
If you went up,
it's to an old node.
So if I told you
a sequence of bits
for every step in the
Euler tour, did I go down
or did I go up, you can
reconstruct the tree.
Now how many bits
do I have to do?
Well, twice the number
of edges in the tree,
because the length
of an Euler tour
is twice the number
of edges in the tree.
So 2 n bits are enough
to encode any tree.
That's the computer
science information
theoretic way to prove it.
You could also do it
from this formula,
but then you'd have to know
why the formula's correct,
and that's messier.
Cool.
So we're almost done.
We have root n possible
different structures down here.
We've got n over
log n of them or--
maybe.
It's a little harder to know
exactly how many of them
there are, but I don't care.
There's only root
n different types,
and so I only need to store
a lookup table for each type.
The number of queries is
order log squared n again,
because our structures
are of size order log n,
and the answer to
a query is again,
order log log n bits,
because there's only log
n different nodes to point to.
And so the total space is
order root n log n squared,
log log n for the lookup table.
And then each of these
triangles stores a pointer,
or I guess, every node
in here stores a pointer
to what tree we're in, or
what type of tree we have,
and also what node in
that tree we are in.
So every guy in here--
because that's not
part of the query--
has to store, not only a little
bit more specific pointer
into this table.
It actually tells you
what the query part is,
or the first part of
the query, the node x.
Then the table also
is parameterized by k,
so one of these logs is
which node you're querying.
The other log is
now the value k,
but again, you never go
up higher than log n.
If you went up
higher than log n,
then you'd be in
the 5 structure,
so if you just do
a query up there,
you don't need a
query in the bottom.
OK.
So there's only
that many queries,
and so space for this lookup
table is little o of n again.
And so we're dominated by
space for these pointers
and for the space up
here, which is linear.
So linear space, constant query.
Boom.
Any questions?
I have an open question, maybe.
I think it's open.
So what if you want to do
dynamic, 30 seconds of dynamic?
For LCA, it's known
how to do dynamic LCA
constant operations.
The operations are add a leaf--
we can add another leaf--
given an edge.
Subdivide that edge into
that, and also the reverse.
So I can erase a guy, put
the edge back, delete a leaf,
those sorts of things.
Those operations can all be
done in constant time for LCA.
What about level ancestor?
I have no idea.
Maye we'll work on it today.
That's it.